المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا جعل البلاد تنشغل
عن الكثير من الملفات الداخليه ابرز هذه
الملفات الانتخابات الرئاسيه هو
البرلمانيه المقبله والتي ستجرى في نهايه
المطاف في موعدها دون اي تغيير
فريسوجان اعلن ان الانتخابات ستجرى في
موعدها المحدده في 14 من مايو المقبل
واثرت الشكوك بشان امكانيه اجراء
الانتخابات في موعدها بعد الزلزال المدمر
واثر الزلزال بشكل واضح على الحملات
الانتخابيه التي كانت تسير بشكل جيد وقت
وقوع الكارثه ونقلا مع وكاله رويترز فان
مسؤولا تركيا قال ان الكارثه خلقت صعوبات
جامه امام اجراء الانتخابات في موعلها
سيما على المستوى اللوجستي وكانت المناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال تضم حوالي ثمانيه
ملايين ناخب مسجل اي ما يعادل 14% من
الناخبين المتوقع ان يبث المجلس الاعلى
للانتخابات في تركيا في كيفيه اجراء
الاقتراع في تلك الولايات او ما اذا كان
يمكن اجراء الاقتراع هناك من الاساس
ولا يبدو واضحا مدى تاثير الزلزال على
حمووض اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
فهناك بعض الانتقادات التي وجهت اليه من
المعارضه بسبب بطء وتيره استجابه الحكومه
عقب حدوث الزلزال الى جانب اكتشاف سوء
البنيه التحتيه ووجود حالات غش كثيره في
عمليات البناء ما ادى الى فتح تحقيق
واعتقال العديد من المقاولين واصحاب
الشركات البناء اما مؤيدوا اردوغان فيرون
ان الانطلاقه السريعه لجهود اعاده البناء
ودعم المتضررين من شانه ان يرفع من اسهم
الرئيس التركي في الانتخابات القادمه
[موسيقى]
حاله ترقب تعيشها مدينه اسطنبول بعد تداول
العديد من الشائعات التي تشير الى امكانيه
حدوث زلزال قوي في اكبر المدن التركيه
بلديه اسطنبول اخذت الموضوع على محمل الجد
من خلال اعلان رئيسها اكرم المغلو عن خطه
شامله لمواجهه خطر الزلازل وهذا الزلزال
المتوقع بالتحديد في مدينه اسطنبول وتاتي
الخطه وسط توقع الجهات الرسميه ومختصين في
الزلزال في الزلازل عفوا بان مدينه
اسطنبول معرضه بحكم موقعها لخطر حدوث
زلزال كبير بقوه تتجاوز
7.5 درجه على مقياس وتقدر الجهات المختصه
في تركيا ان عشرات الالاف من المباني في
مدينه اسطنبول معرضه للانهيار الكامل حال
وقوع زلزال بهذه